[Music]
in fake it till you make it news oh yeah
baby always making it never making it
that's my girl submitted by Kevin love's
JK hey Kevin the music streaming service
title is being accused of faking
hundreds of millions of plays for its
artists owners what's like a jay-z
audible thing so they're inflating their
own numbers yeah well that's kind of
shady but I have never even heard of
them so make it till you fake it cuz
they've already made it that's why they
had to fake it my friends cuz it didn't
go very well yeah I think they were on
their high horse what they're like we're
only gonna release a couple albums on
title like that was what they're gonna
do and then what ended up happening is
when they dropped it no one cares so
they still released it on iTunes it was
a big flop yes so this Norwegian
newspaper
thank goodness for investigative
Norwegians they really affected their
economy huh yeah they're open-faced
sandwich it just shows you how the
wooden shoes market is really taking a
hit yeah how blissful their life is out
there that they have nothing better to
do but to look at [ __ ] title so
apparently they were given this hard
George Norwegian people have such a
great life yeah so this newspaper said
that they were given this hard drive
containing internal company plate data
and so apparently they're saying that
lemonade by Beyonce and life of Pablo by
Kanye West were both the numbers were
inflated like crazy to the point where
they interviewed this one person is 34
year old from Washington DC his law
student and asked her if she could
verify that the plays that were in that
hard drive were hers which were it was
about 11 hours straight so 15 plays of
lemonade in one day by that one person
she was like I love Beyonce but not 11
hours worth like that's crazy so who
would admit to it if they were elicited
Eminem for 11 hours I think I have many
times do when I was a kid listening to
those Disney Disney songs in the car I
we definitely nailed out 11 hours no
doubt no doubt was my jam
yeah no Della's time no not no doubt
like the Aladdin soundtrack okay Lion
King on his way back Lion King was the
best Elton John taught me what was that
one we're the circle of life yeah
vagabond oh yeah what's a vagabond guns
and ragga bonds but he taught me that
word fun we should look at that look it
up vagabond a person who wanders from
place to place without a home or job so
it's just a Papa simple with a vagabond
what why don't they call homeless people
vagabonds I like that better and it
sounds like James Bond yeah do you have
a Gabbar has emotional or wander about
[ __ ] bag upon but see if the homeless
guy held up a sign and said I am NOT
homeless I am a vagabond I'd be like
sounds classy I can't imagine what that
that pitch meeting was though for that
for the Lion King for that Elton John
song it's like well this song is gonna
be two line [ __ ] and he's like look
[ __ ] fine though she was on her back
and he's like on top of her and then the
cameras there I was just like that's how
lions do it though right they doesn't
get on their back you're right these new
Lions yeah they like it from behind
that's true like they should Wow
okay if you look away I just spitting
fits very porn it is true that was not
very damn hopefully not like you would
say you made it too real she's bragging
again I pay attention to the details
alright so yeah
so this whole title bells plays thing
yeah apparently this newspaper is
accusing title of fabricating 320
million false screams yeah 20 million so
there was this announced announcement by
title last year claiming that the life
of Pablo was streamed 250 million times
in the first 10 days and it was also
claimed to have three million
subscribers which means that each user
played the record eighty three times
there's only three million subscribers
that's what they're claiming see who
watches the Watchmen dude
this is what the whole point of that is
right it's like so you're gonna tell
advertisers that this is what your
information is but who's gonna check you
get your information
you're responsible for it and they were
also mentioning that Wes was said to
have requested his streaming numbers
from the platform to be withheld so it
kind of makes it a little as in Kanye
West yeah yeah I've never heard it was
that no one has ever said was and I was
like I don't know what that is but I'm
not shut up because I want to look like
I know yeah well that's what articles
always do they always put there sir West
West like they've taught me I read it
directly to mr. West at that point mr.
Webb is Snoop Dogg mr. dog
he is mr. human mr. dog that's correct
Gigi like if you're his valet you're
like mr. dog miss Keith mr. dog they're
also pointing out the fact that like so
with titles user or artists so it's like
by them fabricating these numbers are
pretty much giving the piece of that pie
mainly to Beyonce and Kanye rather than
like the smaller artists because of
those inflated streaming number so it
just seems really [ __ ] up if this is
true that's what YouTube does that's
what YouTube does they picked the people
that they want to promote and then those
people get a lot of advertising revenue
and it's like oh cuz their numbers are
bigger but YouTube's the one that made
their numbers bigger so you're the one
that come up wait how do they make them
bigger they promote them and the feature
the front page you're telling me they
use some kind of algorithmic the
to promote people yeah and it got proven
when Logan Paul got cut you just don't
JT he got kicked out super Club that
gets promoted
you're just jaded and mad about it
that's true I'm very mad about it aren't
you you know I think it's great what is
wonderful it's awesome everyone should
get separated but for no reason just
have someone select you to be the one
I'll never forget and this is no offense
to the guy but like overnight
the vsauce guy like just [ __ ] his
channel rocketed to the top
oh yeah algorithmically like something
changed and then like all of a sudden
all of his videos started getting added
to the sidebars of everything cuz they
bought him or something like that yeah
and then um same with YouTube nation
YouTube decided to start a channel
called YouTube [ __ ] into [ __ ] gone now
it just yeah it's disintegrated but
YouTube nation would constantly have 11
million views tons of subscribers
overnight and it was because it was
owned by YouTube shady that's crazy
did you guys watch that co-broker I did
I actually bought YouTube red for watch
to watch it yeah I keep that same thing
would you think alright it's really
cheesy but in a good way how cool like a
90s throwback cheesy was the guy who did
the original karate committed right yeah
and then Will Smith is an executive
producer on it so is um someone I forgot
yeah what's the first to admit that's
kind of random for me why well his son
was in the other Karate Kid right so
that maybe he owns part of it somehow
yeah I want I watched the first two
episodes and I thought it was like the
writing was good and they did their best
with the adapting it's pretty like they
make fun of it but the production value
drives me insane why is it there it
feels like we recorded it with ourselves
it's like wits like you we shot it yeah
it's like nuts man Wow cuz they're like
it's going on YouTube anyway let's make
it okay yeah right it just doesn't I
don't know man it's pretty good trying
to make YouTube bread a premium thing
there's no other China it's like it's
like it's it's like TV that's up out
there right now but like
cheap TV it feels like a film student
yeah it does get better like the story
wise it does get so much better no I
thought the story was good yeah like I
was interested in the whole time it's
just to go out of the way it was shot I
was like did you watch the whole season
no I watched the first two episodes yeah
but beyond that like it gets better and
bad done okay like production qualities
you want I mean that's I guess the story
gets better so it sucks you in okay I
already sent me a story already in Japan
for sure but yeah it's good it was it
produced by YouTube where they funded
the production or was it like the
thinning where they bought it from it
was already produced do you know I'm
saying that's true it could have been
that yeah good question but they're
promoting the crap out of it and they're
continuing that world so good that if
you were a kid and you remember watching
Karate Kid and you loved it
you're gonna love this yeah I like to
sponsored by Cobra Kai yeah you didn't
see it coming did you
no it's not sponsored
[Music]